BREAKING NEWS IN THE OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT FROM THE MUELLER WITCH
HUNT.
HERE’S WHAT YOU NEED TO KNOW.
FIRST, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL’S
MEMO ON PAUL MANAFORT IS OUT.
IT’S HEAVILY REDACTED.
WE KNOW, HOWEVER, THAT ROBERT
MUELLER BELIEVES THAT PAUL
MANAFORT BRIEFED HIS PLEA DEAL
AND LIED TO INVESTIGATORS ALL
SURROUNDING ALLEGED CRIMES, NONE
OF WHICH HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, NONE OF
WHICH HAVE TO DO WITH RUSSIA OR
ANYTHING TO DO WITH COLLUSION.
INSTEAD, A SOURCE WITH KNOWLEDGE
OF THE INVESTIGATION TONIGHT
TELLING FOX NEWS THAT MUCH OF
THE REDACTED INFORMATION LIKELY
INCLUDES POTENTIAL CRIMINAL
ALLEGATIONS WE’RE TOLD AGAINST
TONY PODESTA.
THAT WOULD BE JOHN PODESTA’S
BROTHER.
JOHN PODESTA THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN CHAIR.
NOTHING.
NOW WE’RE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
MANAFORT CASE.
TAX EVASION, OTHER CHARGES.
BANK LOAN APPLICATIONS DATING
BACK TO 2007.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS ISSUED THIS
STATEMENT.
SAID "THE GOVERNMENT’S FILING IN
MR. MANAFORT’S CASE IS NOTHING
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
IT SAYS EVEN LESS ABOUT
COLLUSION.
IT’S DEVOTED ALMOST ENTIRELY TO
LOBBYING-RELATED ISSUES AND I’LL
ADD LONG BEFORE PAUL MANAFORT
EVER MET DONALD TRUMP."
ALSO BREAKING TODAY, TWO
SEPARATE SENTENCING MEMOS WERE
FILED AGAINST MICHAEL COHEN.
FIRST, THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NORTHERN COMPLETELY REJECTING
COHEN’S PLEAS FOR LENIENCY
WRITING THAT A SUBSTANTIAL TERM
OF IMPRISONMENT IS WARRANTED AND
THEN THE MEMO SAYS COHEN’S
DECISION TO PLEAD GUILTY RATHER
THAN SEEK A PARDON FOR HIS
CRIMES DOES NOT MAKE HIM A HERO.
IN EXCHANGE FOR COHEN’S GUILTY
PLEA, THE PROSECUTOR’S
RECOMMENDED ONLY A SLIGHT
REDUCTION TO THE SUGGESTED
FIVE-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE.
THE NEXT MEMO FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THAT FOCUSED ON COHEN
ADMITTING THAT HE LIED UNDER
OATH TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SAYING THE SENTENCE SHOULD
REFLECT THE FACT THAT LYING TO
INVESTIGATORS HAS REAL
CONSEQUENCES.
LET’S BE CLEAR.
THE ONE THING THAT THESE TWO
FILINGS HAVE IN COMMON.
NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA OR
COLLUSION AT ALL.
ZERO EVIDENCE IN ANY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS OF TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION, ZERO.
THE PRESIDENT APPLAUDED THE
RULING.
HE TWEETED TOTALLY CLEARS THE
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
THE PRESIDENT’S ATTORNEY, RUDY
GULIANI, CALLED THESE FINDINGS
COMPLETE EXONERATION OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE NOTHING.
WE’RE HAPPY ABOUT IT.
THE PRESIDENT AND GULIANI ARE
RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID DON’T EVER
THINK ABOUT MAKING A DEAL WITH
MUELLER BECAUSE IT’S NOT GOING
TO WORK OUT WHEEL FOR YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> RIGHT NOW IT DOES NOT SOUNDS
LIKE IT’S GOOD NEWS FROM
MUELLER.
DOESN’T SOUND LIKE IN COHEN THEY
HAVE FOUND A WITNESS THAT WILL
GIVE THEM THE KEY TO THE
KINGDOM.
SO FAR THE ONLY SOLID EVIDENCE
HE’S PROVIDED IS THE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION ISSUE, AND IT’S A
VERY WEAK CASE.
>> Sean: TONIGHT WE HAVE TWO MEN
FACING YEARS BEHIND BARS, A
THIRD ONE, GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
WHO WAS RELEASED TIED WHO WAS
JAILED FOR LYING TO
INVESTIGATORS.
THE QUESTION IS FOR WHAT?
WHEN YOU READ THESE DOCUMENTS,
WE HEAR ABOUT TAXI MEDALLIONS,
FRAUDULENT LOAN APPLICATIONS,
TAX EVASION.
LYING ABOUT A POTENTIAL PROJECT
IN MOSCOW THAT NEVER GOT OFF THE
IN MOSCOW THAT NEVER GOT OFF THEGROUND AND WHETHER THEY STOPPED
GROUND AND WHETHER THEY STOPPED
TALKING ABOUT IT IN JANUARY IN
2016 OR JUNE IN 2016.
THE HORROR.
HOW WILL AMERICA EVER RECOVER.
CLEARLY AN ELECTION WAS STOLEN
BY THIS INFORMATION AFTER MONTHS
OF INTENSE INVESTIGATIONS,
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF YOUR DOLLARS SPENT,
SEEDY PERJURY TRAPS, LEGAL
COERCION?
WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
OF ANY WRONG DOING BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THEN YOU ASK YOURSELF THIS
QUESTION, DO YOU FEEL SAFER
TONIGHT?
DO YOU FEEL SAFER THAT A
LOW-LEVEL CAMPAIGN VOLUNTEER
SPENT HIS 12 DAYS IN JAIL FOR
ALLEGEDLY LYING TO THE OMNI
POTENT ROBERT MUELLER?
DO YOU FEEL SAFE THE AMERICAN
MILITARY HERO, LIEUTENANT
GENERAL FLYNN HAD TO SELL HIS
HOUSE THE PAY HIS LEGAL BILLS?
OH, THE THANKS ONE GETS FOR 33
YEARS OF SERVICE TO HIS COUNTRY,
FIVE OF THOSE YEARS IN COMBAT.
BY THE WAY, NEITHER COMEY,
McCABE, STRZOK OR ANYBODY IN THE
FBI THOUGHT HE LIED.
THEY PUT THE SCREWS TO FLYNN AND
HE HAD TO COMPOSE A LIE AND HE
DID IT TO GET OUT OF THE MESS
THAT THEY WERE PUTTING HIM IN.
YOU FEEL ANY SAFER THAN MICHAEL
COHEN IS GOING TO GO TO PRISON
FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME?
FOR LYING TO CONGRESS?
LYING ON A BANK LOAN
APPLICATION.
TAXI MEDALLION LOANS.
NOT PAYING TAXES.
HE FEELS SAFER KNOWING THAT
MANAFORT MIGHT SPEND THE REST OF
HIS LIFE BEHIND BARS BECAUSE OF
TAX FRAUD AND LIES ON LOAN
APPLICATIONS?
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA.
YEARS BEFORE HE MET TRUMP.
HE FEELS SAFER THAT EVERYONE
SURROUNDING THE PRESIDENT IS
SEEMINGLY TARGETED AND THOSE ON
THE LEFT GET AWAY EVERY SINGLE
DAY SCOT-FREE?
IS THAT THE AMERICA WE WANT TO
LIVE IN?
FIRED FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
WHAT WE LEARNED THIS WEEK ABOUT
HIM.
JOHN SOLOMON REPORTING, WE HAVE
E-MAIL CHAINS THAT PROVE THAT
COMEY AND OTHERS IN OBAMA’S DOJ,
THAT THEY ACTUALLY KNOWINGLY
COMMITTED FRAUD ON A FISA COURT
AND THEY USED HILLARY CLINTON’S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, THE BULK OF THE
EVIDENCE IN THEIR FISA
APPLICATIONS IN THEIR CASE TO
OBTAIN A WARRANT TO SPY ON A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE BY THE
NAME OF CARTER PAGE.
THIS WEEK, KNOWING FULL WELL
THEY DID ALL OF THIS, WE LEARNED
THAT THE INTEL COMMUNITY DID NOT
TRUST THE CONTENTS OF HILLARY’S
TRUST THE CONTENTS OF HILLARY’S BOUGHT AND PAID RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
BOUGHT AND PAID RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY KNOWINGLY
COMMITTED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURTS.
NOT ONCE, NOT TWICE, NOT THREE
BUT FOUR TIMES.
WHERE IS THAT INVESTIGATION TO
JAMES COMEY AND SALLY YATES AND
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT SIGNED ON TO THOSE
FISA APPLICATIONS?
GIVING JUDGING FRAUDULENT,
INCORROBORATED RUSSIAN LIES, NOT
TELLING THE JUDGES THAT IT WAS
DIRECTLY PAID FOR BY THE
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE TO
SPY ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY.
TODAY COMEY TESTIFIED BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
HIS ATTORNEYS PREVENTED HIM FROM
ANSWERING ANY TOUGH QUESTIONS.
DURING A SPENT PRESS CONFERENCE,
HE’S BRUSHING OFF ANY CHARGES
THAT HIS FISA COURT CONDUCT WAS
WRONG AND DISGUSTING.
THINK OF THIS.
REMEMBER, THAT HE’S THE GUY THAT
SIGNED ON TO THE FIRST WARRANT.
THAT WAS IN OCTOBER OF 2016.
BUT THAT MEANS HE HAD TO VERIFY
IT WAS TRUE.
THAT MEANT HE VERIFIED IT THAT
MEAN HE CORROBORATED IT.
THAT MEANS THAT HE IS STANDING
BEHIND IT.
IN JANUARY IN TRUMP TOWER, HE
TOLD DONALD TRUMP,
PRESIDENT-ELECT, THAT IT WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAD TOTAL CONFIDENCE THAT
THE FISA PROCESS WAS FOLLOWED
AND THAT THE ENTIRE CASE WAS
HANDLED IN A THOUGHTFUL WAY BY
THE DOJ AND THE FBI.
THE NOTION THAT FISA ABUSED HERE
IS NONSENSE.
>> NOT EVEN CHRISTOPHER STEELE
BELIEVES HIS OWN DOSSIER.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION USED TO
SPY ON AMERICANS?
IS THAT A LITTLE MORE IMPORTANT
TONIGHT?
I’D THINK IT IS.
WE KNOW THE DOSSIER WAS AND IS A
DEBUNKED LIE.
COMEY NEVER VERIFIED IT.
NOBODY CORROBORATED STEELE’S
SO-CALLED EVIDENCE.
STEELE HIMSELF WOULDN’T STAND BY
IT WHEN QUESTIONED UNDER OATH IN
AN INTERROGATORY DOWN IN GREAT
BRITAIN.
EVEN AFTER IT WAS USED TO OBTAIN
A FISA WARRANT.
EVEN WHEN HE SAID IT WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNPROVEN MONTHS
AFTER THEY HAD THE FISA WARRANT
IN PLACE.
JAMES COMEY, I GUESS HE WILL
SLEEP WELL TONIGHT KNOWING OUR
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL
NEVER HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
SO TOO WILL THESE LIARS.
PEOPLE THAT LIED UNDER OATH.
MICHAEL COHEN IS IN TROUBLE
TONIGHT BECAUSE OF IT.
WHAT ABOUT CHERYL MILLS OR UMA
ABEDIN OR BRUCE OHR, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, JOHN BRENNAN, ANDREW
McCABE?
ERIC HOLDER?
LORETTA LYNCH?
THEY ALL LIED TO AUTHORITIES,
NEVER PROS CUTED OR
INVESTIGATED.
LET’S NOT FORGET ABOUT JAMES
COMEY.
HE LIED TO CONGRESS UNDER OATH.
I DOUBT HE WILL GET THE COHEN
TREATMENT TONIGHT.
THEN YOU HAVE THE KING AND QUEEN
OF CORRUPTION, BILL AND HILLARY
CLINTON.
FROM MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, THE LEADING SUBPOENAED
E-MAILS, ACID WASHING HARD
DRIVES WITH BLEACH.
BUSTING DEVICES WITH HAMMERS AND
BLACKBERRIES, PHONES.
LEVERAGING THEIR POLITICAL
POSITIONS TO RAKE IN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
THIS COUNTRY’S MOST CORRUPT
THE CLINTONS TONIGHT ARE PERHAPS
POLITICIANS AND NEVER EVER BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTSABLE.
THAT MIGHT BE ABOUT TO CHANGE.
JOHN SOLOMON’S BREAKING NEWS
HERE ON THIS PROGRAM LAST NIGHT,
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES RECEIVED
WHISTLE-BLOWER INFORMATION IN
2017 ALLEGING THAT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
WRONG DOING.
MARK MEADOWS HAS CONFIRMED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS HAVE IN FACT
TURNED OVER HUNDREDS OF
FOUNDATION DOCUMENTS FOR
LAWMAKERS AND POTENTIALLY NOW
SHEDDING LIGHT INTO THE
CLINTON’S CLOUD OF CORRUPTION.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT INFORMATION
SURROUNDING QUID PRO QUO
PROMISES WHILE HILLARY CLINTON
WAS SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
CO-MINGLING OF FUNDS WITH THE
FOUNDATION AND THE CLINTON’S
PRIVATE MONEY AND MORE,
INCLUDING ONE GLARING EXAMPLE
WHEN HILLARY CLINTON WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE, REMEMBER
THIS DEAL SIGNED OFF ON SENDING
20% OF OUR URANIUM, THE
FOUNDATIONAL MATERIAL FOR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
BY THE WAY, THIS OCCURRED AS THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION WAS RECEIVING
CLINTON FOUNDATION WAS RECEIVINGMILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARSFROM THE CHAIRMAN OF URANIUM ONE
FROM THE CHAIRMAN OF URANIUM ONE
AND THE BANKS INVOLVED.
WE KNEW PUTIN HAD AN OPERATIVE
INSIDE THE UNITED STATES.
WILLIAM CAMPBELL WAS A SPY
WITHIN THAT NETWORK.
IDENTIFYING MONEY LAUNDERING AND
EXTORTION.
GUESS WHAT?
ROBERT MUELLER WAS THE FBI
DIRECTOR.
PUTIN GOT THE FOOT HOLD INTO OUR
URANIUM MARKET.
THE DEAL HAPPENED AND NOBODY GOT
IN TROUBLE.
THE CLINTONS GOT THEIR MONEY,
THE KICKBACK FOR THE FOUNDATION
IN TERMS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN TERMS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.TONIGHT AN INVESTIGATION WE NOW
TONIGHT AN INVESTIGATION WE NOW
KNOW AS OF YESTERDAY IS ON
GOING.
I SAID OVER AND OVER, IT’S TIME
IN AMERICA TO CARE ABOUT OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC, THAT WE
END A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
MORE GOOD NEWS.
A FEDERAL JUDGE AGREES WITH ME.
JUDGE ROYCE LAMBERT OVERSEEING
JUDICIAL WATCH’S FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT LAWSUIT THAT
INVOLVING HILLARY’S SECRET
SERVER SAGA DROPPED A MAJOR BOMB
SHELL ABOUT JUST HOW FAR THE
GOVERNMENT IS WILLING TO GO TO
SKIRT TRANSPARENCY LAWS WRITING
"AT BEST THE STATE’S ATTEMPT TO
PASS OFF ITS SUFFICIENT SEARCH
AS LEGALLY ADEQUATE DURING
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATIONS WAS
NEGLIGENCE BORNE OUT OF
INCOMPETENCE.
AT WORST, CAREER EMPLOYEES IN
THE STATE AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENTS COLLUDED TO SCUTTLE
PUBLIC SCRUTINY OF CLINTON,
SKIRT FOYA, AND HOODWINK THIS
COURT."
HE DIDN’T STOP THERE.
CALLING THE CLINTON E-MAIL
AFFAIR, ONE OF IF GRAVEST MODERN
OFFENSES TO GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY.